Nearly everything we buy is made overseas.
No matter where you live, it’s likely that
the majority of products you use on a daily
basis are made outside your own country’s
borders.
Even at the supermarket it’s common to see
fresh food that was grown or caught on the
other side of the world.
Not long ago, this would have been unheard
of.
Everything had to be produced close to the
consumer.
It just wasn’t profitable to ship goods
over long distances.
Only luxury and specialty items were shipped
from overseas.
Very few commonplace items were produced more
than a couple hundred miles away from the
final market.
That all changed on April 26, 1956, when the
Ideal-X, a converted World War Two tanker
left Newark, New Jersey on its maiden journey.
What was so special about this journey was
that it was the first time in history that
a ship had its cargo packed into containers,
rather than just loosely placed throughout
its holds.
This seems like a simple and uninfluential
concept, but this idea changed our world.
Before the Ideal-X, cargo was brought to port
in trucks and loaded onto ships piece-by-piece.
Whisky and rice and hammers and everything
was packed tightly in the hold, and the whole
loading process took more than a week.
This technique, known as break bulk cargo,
dated back to the time of the Phoenicians.
It was said that the dock workers wages were
“twenty dollars a day and all the Scotch
you could carry home,” because theft of
goods was so rampant.
This needed to change.
Malcolm McLean, a trucking company owner,
sold everything he owned to buy a ship and
develop the system of containerization.
Unbearably simple, he designed a corrugated
steel box and created some trucks and a ship
that would seamlessly hold these boxes.
This connected the manufacturer straight to
the consumer.
Manufacturers would load these boxes, then
no hands would touch the merchandise until
the container was delivered to the vendor,
distributor, or consumer.
One of the most amazing aspects of this system
of this system it became universal.
We can’t even agree on currency, plug type,
DVD standard, or even which side of the road
to drive on but we can agree, across the world,
on the one size of shipping container.
A container loaded in Kansas will fit on the
train that takes it to the dock, then fit
on the boat that takes it to China, then fit
on the truck that will take it up to Russia.
Even some planes are now being designed to
fit intermodal containers.
Theres no need for logistics, no need for
calculations, no need for worrying if the
container will work in faraway countries.
But what really changed our world was how
quick this system made the loading process
of a ship.
What used to take more than a week could now
be done in a matter of hours.
Shipping costs plummeted after the introduction
of this system.
Whole cities, such as Newark and Oakland were
put on the map because of their new, larger
ports that were needed in response to the
shipping boom.
This system also helped create the global
economy that we have today, one where one
car has elements from dozens of countries
across the world.
Its now cheaper to manufacture many goods
on the other side of the world because shipping
is so inexpensive.
Containerization was the greatest driver of
the development of a global economy and trade
network.
The intermodal container cut shipping time
from Europe to Australia down from 70 to 34
days without increasing the speed of the travel.
We are still witnessing the aftermath of this
innovation today.
Between 1993 and 2002, the average distance
of a cargo shipment grew by 40%.
This means that goods are still being manufactured
farther and farther away from their market.
The value per ton of cargo is also dropping.
More and more cheap items are being shipped
from far away to be sold.
However, many believe that containerization
could have been the last great innovation
in shipping.
Boats can’t really go any faster while still
being profitable.
15 knots is the average speed today for cargo
ships and it’s unlikely that this speed
will increase in the near future.
To make shipping faster and cheaper, one needs
to find other ways to speed up the process.
There are some small changes being developed,
such as the automatization of ports and the
further specialization of ships, however the
greatest innovation for shipping may come
from the greatest threat to mankind.
Global warming is opening new routes for shipping.
The once frozen Northeast passage north of
Scandinavia and Russia now can be sailed on
for a few months of the year.
In 2009, a German cargo ship became the first
commercial vessel to sail this route, and
today multiple ships use this route every
year.
The route shortens the shipping time between
Europe and Asia by days, avoid the pirate
infested waters of the Red Sea and Gulf of
Aden, and saves on average $300,000 in fuel
per vessel per voyage.
So there you have it.
Thats how a metal box changed our world.
Without that box we wouldn’t have our phones
from China, our clothes from Bangladesh, or
even our oranges from Florida.
Freight shipping is the behind the scenes
process that has made our world what it is
today.
Our economy and our lives would not be the
same without this innovation.
Containerization may be little known, but
its affects are more evident than almost any
other invention of the 20th century.